a lot a very warm welcome to this latest
edition of talking Germany the show
where we do just that and with me here
in the studio today is a man perhaps who
more than any other personifies one of
the most potent and popular music genres
here in Germany in recent decades the
music is techno the man is westbam areas
with me thanks very much for joining me
here in the studio today on top of
desert great stuff damn Oh westbam known
simply to his friends as quite simply
Maximilian lense is currently marking 30
years in the music business 30 years
that is as a DJ and producer and he's
doing so in grand style with a new album
that has a host of big names on vocals
like kenya west little wayne and Iggy
Pop one of my favorites to mention just
a few so there's plenty to talk about
and plenty to look forward to our first
question West Pamela a leading German
magazine recently called you and I'm
quoting the graying godfather of techno
the grey ink there's wonderful yeah I
like my great beer just to show
everybody show off my gray beard look
like what is techno good question the
traditional definition of techno is it's
music that sounds like machines and not
machines that sound like music I did you
say that's the traditional definition is
that I definition that you're ok with
you're happy with how well you know like
when we talk of of techno as like this
big youth culture that doesn't that
doesn't apply because especially in
Germany different to say England techno
is the name for everything that was
played on the love rate for everything
with the fall to the floor beat they see
our this all this technology and it goes
boom boom boom it's check now but it's I
feel there's a much wider definition
then of what technoculture it made a
wider to give me give me the wider
definition in one sentence put it into
put it into a nutshell well for me the
you know like the word technol always
implies is so much about we want to
sound futuristic
as if you take like big trends like you
know when they used to cut up this or
disco records you know that doesn't
follow the aesthetics of kraftwerk
enough of the idea we just use synthetic
sounds you know you use whatever you can
to make modern music it's techno still
around is it still relevant is it still
out there well it's you know like a lot
of people ask me about this and they say
well in the early 90s it was such a big
thing and then when I go back to the
early 90s and say in Berlin we talk
about 23 small clubs that would play
check now all the rest of the clubs will
play something else if you look now in
Berlin you get like 100 clubs playing
this you know back then you had like 20
DJ's here in Berlin or maybe 30 now I
don't want to exaggerate but I think
like if you count although you know the
people from Canada or whoever core djs
that came to Berlin you get like 10,000
DJ's these days in Berlin I guess you
know that was and yeah there's you know
you know that's a figure and and I've
heard like a figure that half of the
kids these days want to become DJ stuff
like it's all djs DJ's well let's stop
regular DJ I'm looking at your hat all
the while I yes kick it like a sensor
yeah yeah yeah that is one of the tracks
off of your new album gotta start yeah
the street in the odds yeah just tell me
about the album because you're talking
about techno it's the album techno or is
it something more sort of mainstream is
it pop yeah well you know I think
poppers whatever is popular so I would
hope it should be part after you know in
that way but well I personally I've my
interest was never to follow a fulfill
like this definition of electronic you
know that's for me that kraftwerk is the
group that perfectly does that since the
late 60s 70s you know so and I don't
think there's so much space for like and
a new generation of people to really
make this into their own thing so I
basically I'm quite a conceptional
person I like to take this idea maybe
for a track or two tracks but then I
turn to something else you know because
my whole idea is about freedom about an
icky about surprise you know and about
adventure the graying Godfather as the
anarchy see
I'm always interested in what music
people listen to and I'd like to go
right back to your early days and you
tell me what music your parents listen
to when you were growing up well they
listened to a lot of like hippie-ish
music I remember one time like in in the
early 70s they like this in the
summertime when the MUNGO JERRY monk and
they were really now there is a big body
parts Yeah right and I kind of like it
because it's all a very rhythmical
record but then also and my father would
listen to kraftwerk and I remember that
you know like Autobahn that was very
something oh yeah and then but also the
rolling stones I remember but there was
for me mostly fascinating because of
that Cavill with that big cake and they
were standing on top yeah yeah yeahs out
I think that I'm a trap but I'm not sure
anyone i'm not sure i haven't seen it
since 73 or something if your parents
were hippies yeah sort of
anti-authoritarian people and you are by
in by spirit sort of an anarchist which
is what you've just been telling me how
did you rebel against your parents
because they were already
anti-establishment yeah well but that's
that's where the punk vibe comes in for
the then you know when you had like mum
the funny thing is gonna like my parents
want to meet you I have long hair ya see
like oh don't cut up your long hair yeah
you know so how do you recall will get
you happy that I had long yea yea yea be
yea um um so like the rebellion is like
cut off your hair you're gonna tell the
hair Puntland's tell me about that you
bison by the age of fourteen you were in
a punk Yeah Yeah right I I was the bass
player we were the bass player right mmm
you know and you know like I had heroes
like jean jacques brunel off the
stranglers mm-hmm Sid Vicious of course
she couldn't play the bass but you know
he held it so deep I love that thank you
play your bass down here yeah I love
that and then you saw you were like you
were in a punk band yes on the base yeah
and then also synthesized are so
because I was going to ask you how do
you get from Punk to techno yeah well
they're like two different worlds as far
as like yeah well well that's the
interesting thing that the early german
new wave and also in the british but in
the german maybe even more so we're a
big influence from synthesizer music you
know it yet groups groups like da f you
had groups like Devlin from England you
would have groups like an effete gadgets
like you know like a lot of groups like
throbbing gristle and stuff that would a
cabaret voltaire they always you know
had like just the beatbox and just a
squeaky sound and just vote cold or
something so electronic new wave was
already like I mean I'm not a punk from
7679 any and on these days you know it
was like it was like a platform for all
types of new avant-garde istic music
yeah you know so okay so while you were
doing all that the next step was you
left your hometown of Munster and you
came to live in Berlin yeah what year
was that well I came here already as a
as a puncture is like kids from from
West Germany would there were like a
little bit alternative or whatever would
always like you know would always go to
Berlin you know because that was the
place where the mecca of German youth
culture huh so you had all kinds of you
know like you know the best one German
youth movement called de papa the you
know yeah dad yet of rockabilly people
you had punk rockers yet new romantic
people you had whatever you know gothic
whatever kind of focus turns out that
was the music that was going on but what
tell me about Berlin at the time when
you arrived here Berlin in the 1980s
because this was a city that still had a
wall around Yeah Yeah right I mean one
good reason to go for like a young male
a person would have been you would there
you wouldn't have to go to the army Anna
that that's one one reason that's why
Berlin would attract like a while people
that have have a different concept in
life and wouldn't take the the normal
way because like on the other hand like
Berlin obviously was a place where was
not the chopped career place yeah you
know also in music or whatever you know
because it was just that island
surrounded by a wall it would rather
attract weirdos ok yeah the weirdo and
yeah I'm gonna what we're going to talk
about what happened after that going
from the 1980s into the 1990s in just a
short bit I'd like to come forward today
oh to where you are now we've mentioned
the album gutter shots already streets
of the gods yeah let's just get a clip
from the album and listen to listen to
one track from the album just a wee
little bit yeah and then you can tell me
a little bit about it no no here we go
go
max yeah westbam that's it I like the
album very very much indeed i have to
say yeah and you talked earlier about
sort of being you seeing yourself as a
conceptual artist and musician producer
was the word you used and when i was
listening to the album listen to an
awful lot the last week while I've been
doing my research it seemed to me that
it's a concept album to use a little bit
of an old-fashioned term would you
accept that yes yeah well young like for
me an album doing and albums always an
adventure and I tried to not repeat
myself too much and the concept of that
album has to do with the fact that I've
been teaching her for 30 years you know
so I wanted to do something not just
another tool album or something that I
could easily throw in my mix but
something that would reflect my
experience of nightlife with over the
last 30 years and so to see from a very
distant perspective almost like a view
on the nightlife scene from outer space
gsl that's that's and that's basically
the concept so I you know like I try to
get together all these different kind of
voices you know and I've been very
ambitious not just to take certain
things from a certain background but
bring together like voices of the world
you know like from different ages and
different musical experiences and trying
to melt it into one big concept how long
what that was the danger because you had
all these very different voices it was
it and I can imagine it was a difficult
get a unity out of that but that's I
think in the pound
max westbam yeah you were there yeah we
just had this kind of armor of the 1990s
yeah what did it mean to you what does
it mean to you when you look back well
it was the the age of euphoria do you
know like and Berlin was a symbol for
that and that's why I think whether like
all the importance of Berlin also for
youth culture in that decade came from
basically and the fame that the Berlin
has until today as a like a night live
city in a city of all this you know of
these sensations that's that's coming
from the 90s and with the wall coming
down yet this age of you know especially
with the kids from East Germany
celebrating yet the idea wow you know
you know the this idea at the end of
history now everybody's gonna live free
argh you know everybody can have like a
great job have choices have chances and
then and then at the end of the decade
because what you're talking about is
events at the beginning of the egghead
essentially from the fall of the berlin
wall in 1989 this is where the feel for
that decade began this city and then at
the end of the decade yeah yeah they've
got a 911 that's very different movie
that's 911 stop that feeling and you
could see that in the music is again a
look and that euphoric music there was
electro music there was driven so much
by the big rave signals that would
signal oh great times are coming that
went away and gave space to this quiet
minimal music that would reflect people
answer sure of themselves of their
society you know other people don't like
us so much maybe we don't have the best
system well let's stick among ourselves
let's meet and little clubs and let's be
quiet that's not you know the the whole
idea you want to express to the world
how great everything is that all went
away and gave room to this
a little bit more pessimistic a little
bit more quiet a little bit more private
idea yeah I've had experience yet and
it's interesting because you were
involved in the Love Parade you've
mentioned the Love Parade already which
began in Berlin and went right through
the decade yeah yeah and then moved away
from Berlin yeah and by 2010 it was
actually being staged in the Western
German city of duisburg as you well know
well they took it from Berlin and they
would change it around the raw area so
what they wanted to take it to a new
city in that area every year so it the
first said it in Essen and then they
moved to dart Wanda and that on that
tragic year them had moved it to do
sports just explained for the viewers so
that they know I think very many of our
viewers will remember this terrible
catastrophe at the love parade I mean
it's it's a it's an event called a love
parade yeah there's a stampede yeah 21
people are killed hundreds were injured
terrible scene yeah I think what was it
how did you first hear about this story
what can you remember the moment when
people told you what was happening well
um I flew in from my holidays in my orca
typical German and um on my arrival I
get messages and they said well it's so
sad that things would end this way you
know and I didn't understand it at first
because I had decided for myself that it
would be my last love rate because I
felt a little bit alienated whether or
not new people that did it and I felt
now this is not exactly my thing now
more so I'm going to stop and I was the
last one of the original people who was
there the year before I'd seen I stood
backstage I didn't know anybody no more
and I felt like I I don't want to be a
part I can't really be a part of this no
more so it was my personal goodbye so
when I get the message i well it's so
sad that things stop I thought well you
know but it's going to go on because i
didn't realize i thought people were
talking to me about my personal goodbye
to the LA Freya so there was a
and then it's slowly dropped on me what
was happening and then well I want you
the whole channel and then then they
pumped me up and said don't you wanna
play no more the police said we have to
keep it going you know and I thought do
I have to play now you did for security
reasons or didn't play and then I
decided no this is not right you know I
said first you didn't plan yeah I know
that you don't know just tell me what
your emotion give me one word for your
emotion how you actually felt when you
realized what had happened there well
well it's it's it's you know you can't
explain that's just a shock you know a
shock moment is where you you don't
understand really oh you know you've
just standing there thinking what's
happening it was no comprehensive yeah
right you know and yeah that's why I
when they called me up and said you have
to play I thought maybe I have to go and
play I thought like no I don't want to
play maybe I have to for security
reasons for safety reasons you know but
then I decided now they can play music
on a lower level and I didn't understand
why they would keep it up they at that
point think anybody did I don't think
anybody did okay you know that and there
for me to some extent you know because i
know people said stuff like well these
people who died would have liked justice
party on in their spirit stuff like that
you know i thought it's disgusting in a
car you can't yeah like okay just like
it there yeah yeah but thank you for
sharing that with us she's
we have westbam with us and he is of
course a DJ with 30 years of experience
so the question has to be have you ever
been invited to be a I don't know what a
teacher a lecturer a professor of DJing
and yeah I think I've done this once or
twice but i think is something you know
people trying to make a business out of
teaching people out to be a DJ but it's
it's not something that you can learn a
lot about know that job i don't think
you know think you could tell me jb ozj
you could teach me the technical aspect
Yeah Yeah right but that's you know i
think like what can be charged to people
you can teach them maybe in one or two
days yeah and the rest is experienced
and personality and okay you once said
you once talked about something called
the art of the DJ what is the art of a
DJ well you know for me it had happened
in the early eighties that I've you know
suddenly I became aware of the whole
idea that you could actually not just
make a nice connection between two
records but mixing records and inventing
a new music by it and that's for me the
art you know if it's not a practical
thing you mix a record so people don't
have to stop dancing or they don't lose
the rhythm or anything that's the
practical side but you can do it to
create something new and that's Wandy
the art of the DJ kue when you stop
becoming a punk and moved into techno
and you started DJ to you had two
turntables and you had a pile of Records
mm-hmm right and I add when I started I
started not with a technique when I
started there were like maybe ten DJs in
Germany they could mix it all anyway and
in my own tone of months nobody could do
it and I didn't know how to do it so my
first thing was like playing my favorite
records which is something which is a
good start for a DJ if you have your own
tasty our musical world and that's what
you want to bring across that's the most
important thing I think until today you
know whether you use mp3s or records
that's that's not the question whether
you mix them or you cut them
or whatever you do you know if you have
an idea of what you want to tell people
with your music you know what you want
to select that's until today the best
thing but all those records that you
used to have way back when 30 years ago
what happened to the records where are
they now because you're on digital now
yes but I can't get rid of my records I
don't want to I still so like I when I
bought my new fled i bought a little
flat anima flat just for my records you
haven't so they you having with records
yeah this you know like that's a bit of
luxury but you know I think my records
have taken me all the way you know and I
owe my whole career to my record so I
can't throw away or sell them if I know
they have like a like you know I and
every once a while I go through them I
picked one up and I have a charge here
so I'm I'd you know put one on invite me
around one day to have a look at this or
just the apartment with the rest of
resumes median you made a lot of money
you were very successful you are very
successful yeah my feeling is that you
probably don't ever need to work again
that's correct but you still go out
pretty much monday to friday i hear ya
and you yeah you this that you do you
think you go to a DJ office and do your
djing all or you you you can pose or
what do you do yeah yeah well you know
like I I do something you know even like
people ask me when I don't have a
release for some time and they fancy I
just sit around or sit by the pool and
chill with my drinks but it's it's not
like that I I do this because it's fun
for me you know and like I define myself
by my work to some extent so uh that's
something that I will keep on doing I
don't know whether I can be a DJ by the
age of 80 but I I would still like care
about the music and I think that you
mentioned they get the aspect of getting
older because I read that you you
yourself fear that you're going to need
a hearing aid quite soon well that's
what the doctor said
testing when he tested my ears but you
know there's a German saying mugu
beautiful and shabana meaning well if
you're gonna use your ears the way I
used mine and a higher price you can
have to pay a price at some point you
know so but but it's we're not quite
there yet and you know I'm trying I'm
trying to keep everything so that my
beloved is stay with me for some more
time he's trying to keep the volume yeah
yeah westbam do you go to church at
Christmas I've done so once or twice
with my kids but my kids were still very
young and they were like uh I didn't
want them to shout something you know
like why is this so boring or something
so I was getting a little bit nervous
what their man i left it's interesting
though that you took them along because
you're still sort of taking advantage of
the services of the church and what the
service means a little bit and we just
had that report about people leaving the
church and one reason why we decided on
the report was because you are one of
those people yeah who in growing numbers
are leaving the church in Germany why
did you do it well you know I must
honestly admit it you know when I was in
my trends and I make my first money I
realized i'm paying judge tax and at the
time I wasn't going to church and not
use if you're a member of a church here
in Germany you pay church tax yeah on a
monthly basis yeah and it's quite a bit
of mine extra fifteen percent or
something you know and then okay you
know always people say when they asked
why they left they say well because
we're not in agreement with all of the
stuff that's happening in the church you
know if I'm honest in those days that
the reason for me was to church tax you
know you know that is not to say that I
agree with everything the church does
you know um I I have a fascination with
religion i read religious
books but not only the Bible but also
the Buddhist or the Jewish or the also
dislike quran quran and for me as you
know there's some wisdom and some
fascination in in our religion and just
kind of make your mind up about like
metaphysic thinks it's not a bad thing
you know but it's I you know in that way
I guess I'm typical German you know that
like the whole church cage the way it is
doesn't really apply to me it's very
interesting listening to you saying all
that because you are very typically
German because a lot of people are
leaving the church in Germany but the
church still remains very very important
in Germany no okay we normally finish
the show with the quiz at the end of the
show where I give you quick questions
and quick answers and you give me a
quick answer okay what I've got today is
I've got two questions for you techno
yeah is it a movement a religion or a
party a big party a dance party hr3 it's
all three and who's got the better taste
in music would be talking about parents
and children who's got the better taste
in music you or your kids me round a
pitcher don't tell them when you get
home okay ah but I have to teach them
one day there get there okay that is
your lot with the very engaging mr.
techno westbam oh there's more talking
German including my blog on and our
archived on our website to go there
check it out if you've enjoyed the show
as much as I have who's been a great
guest come back next week until then bye
bye anxious
you